these anonymous traders online saw how
overshorted gamestop was
and they did a legitimate thing they
short squeezed it that's a legitimate
market reaction
they just want the hedge fund investors
to make more money than a common man
but i'm here to say that the common man
wins
litigate them to hell litigation's the
best weapon here's the thing though i
think these guys
factored in litigation they factored in
the sec fines they factored in
everything
they were looking at such tremendous
losses that they are willing to face
possible prosecution and possible
litigation just to screw us over to save
their own behinds
i mean everything's getting worse i mean
if things are
if things are gonna get better we the
people have to take control we can't
wait for the government or for the
bankers to do the right thing
we have to get smarter first off we have
to do our homework
and actually follow the money actually
study the monetary system
and if you follow that all the money
leads to the fed i would argue that's
the market self-regulating because you
have these short sellers
who are over shorting stocks there's
more shorts than there are stocks
and that's a very risky bet so these
guys saw it and they started buying
and they didn't want to budge on their
position so they lost out so that's a
perfect example
of just winning at the game they won
they won and they beat them at their own
game and now they're trying to they're
trying to change the rules on them